Let's see if we can write
1.501 as a percentage.
Now we really just want
to write this quantity
as something over 100.
So what we can do is
we can say that this
is the same thing
as 1.501 over 1.
We haven't changed its value.
And let's multiply
it times 100/100.
When we do this product-- and
I haven't changed the value.
This is just multiplying
something times 1.
But when we do it, we're
going to change the way
that we're representing it.
The denominator now is
going to be 1 times 100.
So that's pretty
straightforward.
That's just going to be 100.
And then the
numerator, we're going
to want to multiply
1.501 times 100.
And so if we multiply
this times 10,
we would move the
decimal one over.
We want to multiply
it by 100, so we
want to multiply by 10 again.
So we're going to move the
decimal over to the right
twice.
We're multiplying
it by 10 twice,
or you're multiplying it by 100.
This is multiplying by 10.
This is multiplying by 100.
So this is where the
decimal's going to sit now.
So we're going to get 150.1.
And so we've rewritten the
1.501 as 150.1 over 100,
or 150.1 per 100.
Let me write that.
150.1 per 100, which
is the same thing
as 150.1 per cent, which is
the same thing as 150.1%.
And we're done.
And, essentially, all
you're doing-- if you really
want to simplify the process--
we're multiplying this
by 100 to get 150.1.
And then we're saying,
that is the percentage.
So you want to make sure that
you write the percent there
or the percent symbol.